moving on two of Hollywood's biggest
names that would be Jennifer Aniston and
Reese Witherspoon
they are teaming up have you heard for a
new show it's called the morning show
they are the leading ladies and
executive producers thank you very much
of the new Apple TV Plus series so we
talked to Jen and Reese that's what we
call them around here about the project
and they revealed how they drew from
their own experience to prepare for the
roles and spoke about why they're so
excited to reunite again on screen we
all know that you all met at friends
years years years eons ago you have no
right to tell me what to do I'm not
telling you what to do I am telling you
what not to do then we keep meeting and
going what movie should we make together
let's do a movie together we've been
around for a while yeah but we never
really found the right thing and then
this came up and it just felt perfect
nearly 20 years later Reese Witherspoon
and Jennifer Aniston are back together
on screen hey co-starring as news
anchors in the morning show the series
was already in development when the
storyline changed this whole other
sexual harassment story started coming
out within the the news world and then
we just were like we have to do this and
we have to address it to her I'm
bringing you some sad and upsetting news
the male anchor played by Steve Carell
is fired for allegations of sexual
misconduct there's big ol elephant on
the couch because CBS was part of the
me2 movement none of us thought we'd be
there either but here we are and so when
that happened and and those stories
started breaking did you guys go I can't
believe this is happening as we're doing
this because it does change the game it
did completely we had to pause and kind
of rethink and regroup and it's very
important to how we sort of hit this in
terms of tone to not try to take any
sides or beat you know to black and
white just for a second let's look at
the larger context of hashtag me too I
feel that people are screaming for an
honest conversation I think this is
happening in real life where men are
looking at each other saying I wasn't as
bad as that guy yes so what is a message
if any that you that the show is trying
to send about that
there are the absolute monsters
consciously doing these disgusting
things and then there's the the Darcis
that just assumed every woman wants to
and of course you're going to come to my
that's just that's not out of the
ordinary at all is there a message for
men in this series do you think probably
watch yourself check yourself at the
door I am curious about the redemption
or is there room for redemption and due
process of men it is something I think
about a lot because I think a woman
makes an accusation yeah and then the
man is instantly found guilty in the
court of public opinion yeah and I think
we have to figure out a way to navigate
that on both sides I think there's great
growth and development by us finally
listening to women who are survivors
really believing but you're completely
right I mean I think people do processes
certainly a situation that you have to
believe in because I always say Reese
this ain't that complicated when men say
oh my god I'm so sure what to do I don't
know how to react yeah you do yeah well
I think it's strange because one set of
rules played for so long and then one
day the rules changed and they changed
pretty abruptly so I think we have to
give everybody a little bit of space to
where we're changing a bit of a learning
curve we're changing what do you mean we
weren't put in leadership positions
before and now people are taking us
seriously people are wanting us to be
the leaders where that wasn't even
opportunity that we had even seven years
ago to be producers of our own material
that was sort of like okay well just
tell her she's a producer but I don't
really listen to her ideas yeah and now
it really feels like know what don't
recent Jenna want the part you guys
never seem to realize is that you don't
have the power anymore alex has got a
great monologue in the boardroom are you
actually trying to justify your actual
listening I don't need to justify
anything
you are so convinced that you are the
rightful owner of all of the power that
it doesn't even occur to you that
someone else could be in the driver's
seat has there come a time in your
career where either of you felt you had
to give a speech like that yeah many
many many many I've been in rooms where
I said is there any women at this
company because I don't want to work
here if I don't see a woman in the room
the next time I come in but I you know
by the way went outside the room and I
was shaking I was like am I gonna get in
trouble am I gonna lose the deal am I
gonna lose the job and I was like screw
it
mm-hmm it's good if I lose the job I
didn't want to work there anyway yeah
you know what I went back and they
brought a bunch of women into the room
see that's amazing I heard you say Jen
that this is one of the most creative
times of your life yes
what do you mean exactly by that meeting
I just feel that I have come into a
place in my life as an actor as a
creative I just feel excited couple you
know yours and you go this would be like
I said about to pasture and it's like
whoa whoa whoa whoa this is all just
getting started I'm just this is I'm
just getting cooking over here and I
think it's about changing those rules
you know that society places on all of
us you're both very successful actresses
but at some point you decided I want to
be a boss I want to know your thought
process behind that for both of you
there's no stories there were no scripts
it's not good enough that we don't have
we don't get to be the lead story of our
own lives because what does that show
the world you know little girls don't
see us being the people we really are we
playing wives and girlfriends yeah
that's the the America's Sweetheart so
it's like just yet to take create the
stories because they're out there
there's a lot that we have to say so
it's just about let's get out there and
we'll do it ourselves listen they are
very proud of their work on this if both
as executive producers there
they've already been picked up I'm told
for the second season so that's going
very well for them and you know they've
they're releasing three episodes
November 1st which is tomorrow and then
you're gonna see it once a week just
sort of build the conversation and have
people talking about it that was made a
big investment yeah and I you know
people are interested in how this
business works guys I was gonna ask you
layers
to see what's what's real and what's not
well we know right I think they did I
think they did I think I recognize a lot
of things in the building no names to be
mentioned it's it's available to stream
on Apple TV Plus which by the way if you
have an iPhone you have Apple TV plus
it's there it's a little black icon you
can find it people are saying how do I
get it it's very easy to get and you can
watch our lightning round of questions
with Jennifer Aniston and Reese
Witherspoon on our CBS this morning
Instagram page
they they were really good sports they
came to play all right check out that
Instagram page